[Music]
in relationship drama new us as [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] nuts banging it submitted by
hello from Tokyo hello hi konichiwa
cornered
whooshing whooshing - like on the phone
story update the pro gamer reveals the
real reason he dubbed the world's
hottest weather girl he does not like
[ __ ] that's why he asked to turn he's
coming up I'll be the judge of hottest
dude have you see this woman no she
really hot she's hot yeah
you think she's hot - yeah that's you
she's hot Wow
normally you have some specific reason
why somebody can't be hot I don't like
actor I don't like actors but for some
reason the Mexican Channel Wow right
maybe that's what it is we tell them oh
no that's true they only hire beautiful
piece yes maybe I don't
well you know it most of them come from
where you could have been a big weather
girl could've been [ __ ] I think I found
it
maybe I just don't like mainstream pop
like American pop culture yeah you like
indeed chicks right no I got a chick in
soap opera was she like you exactly you
like Sofia vergata oh yeah she's hot yes
oh yeah she's from the the the marry
with children guy yeah I will say this
though I remember that dude was actually
pretty [ __ ] good-looking too though
yeah they were meant for each other
[ __ ] handsome oh okay he has like
cartoon sized muscles yeah cartoon he's
like mexican johnny bravo like someone
drew like a picture of a hot guy there
you go but for her she's out of his
League
well I want see he's a pro gamer for
Call of Duty and all that stuff so this
is what she looks like Oh
no no that's not the best way that's not
the best angle to accentuate best it's
personality trait yes I hope you feel
very loved you look so much like these
women it's crazy
she does she has a similar bootie bootie
oh the bootie that's yeah it's crazy how
the headset makes the guy look like 100
percent less hot like a nerd
yeah like the [ __ ] car headset the
opposite of what baseball hats do I
think baseball hats make every guy look
super that's true but like I didn't have
that on and maybe he wasn't in like a
[ __ ] racer chair why don't they
always have racer chair
he looks like he's gonna be a call
center like employers yeah yeah exactly
he's gonna help you with your [ __ ]
phone bill and [ __ ] he's the hottest
phone operator what if he has a voice
that's not sex that's like dude so a
couple years ago my xbox was broken and
I called the Xbox Help Center thing and
it was like whoa dude sorry your Xbox is
broken bro like that was the [ __ ]
voice like the automated voice I was
like - Nicole thing yeah who's hilarious
okay here's another photo again that
Kirsty oh [ __ ]
I wonder laundry makes everyone look
good - it's not even that I would
literally pay her to step on my throat
yeah I let her show me absolutely one
and I thank her yeah yes I want to [ __ ]
on you you know that's gross but you
were talking about that he loves you
Jess could be a Mexican weather girl
yeah is she yeah she's Mexican a lot of
Mexicans look like like Jess like they
have like similar features really yes
its widest black though yeah there are
white Mexicans all over the place for
sure Jess is not Mexican you know you
look at my grandma's side of the family
she looks really white to me he just
looks like such an all-american like
it's 1960s movie star yeah yeah she has
a vintage look
yeah I love that look she looks like she
could be racist but she is she looks
like she had like some you know
why are we complimenting Jess this isn't
fun you think that's a compliment saying
that she looks racist no no that was fun
well what's with all this like she's the
glam star and [ __ ] no I'm just saying it
wasn't like I was saying she doesn't
look beautiful just because she doesn't
look Mexican I was just get back on
message and have fun poking and poking
each other not build each other off I
like to poke her butt yeah well they we
talked about them in the past because
they were making headlines because
Douglas said that he broke up with you
net because he wanted to focus on his
Call of Duty gaming that was like you
know what she's a sweet girl but it's
just not gonna work out except getting
in the way why this girl want to be with
him so bad I know why bigamy
has his kill death ratio was way off
maybe I could he's also a gajillion heir
maybe he has a big day that's all I can
think of no but she's making money -
she's a would not like it though girls
don't make money your own thing yeah I
don't know if I'm make enough money to
put food on the table I don't give a
[ __ ] about how much money someone makes
I do I do because then they could give
me business trip tickets and [ __ ] yeah
well that's a part that's a perk but
they didn't put up with their shitty
attitude for that nah I'm gonna be okay
away from them I feel like everybody got
shitty attitude true we're all people
not me good one you're perfect have a
great attitude so anyway so then douglas
ends up retiring from gaming so it looks
like [ __ ] like why would you break up
with her if you're saying you want to
focus on gaming and now you're retiring
from being me like what the [ __ ] is your
problem so then all these people are
just like that's a good I know okay this
is what happening the cartel they both
have really big followings the cartel
says you cannot love her because
El Chapo wants her hmm
and then he was like to keep her alive I
must break up with her dude if El Chapo
really rare Mexico how come she's not
like absconded with him you know I'm
saying yeah that gives me hope
he got extradited oh that's true I think
so oh yeah he's in jail now
now he came out with this video
explaining the real reason yeah why he
broke or knew it because he just got
tired of all like the mocking like just
people just keep telling him that he
took a big L and all this [ __ ] well you
did yeah so then he was like alright
well he was trying to be as respectful
as possible she did on him that's so
funny that got the whole world put
values over him and on her look is like
oh you lost a big one there it's like
what if she was a horrible person what
if she repeatedly cheats on him [ __ ] and
throws hot water on him and like you're
not dude some of the hottest people I've
ever known are the most boring people
I've ever known or crazy are you saying
I'm not hot or I'm boring you guys I
think you're interesting how about no
you're a great case you're a great case
because because everybody should get
with the ugly duckling where do you
blossom later okay love to no no but the
thing is not her she's beautiful they
don't know the struggles they don't know
the struggles everybody here is an ugly
duckling so we all know the struggles
yeah but why are people talking about
him like he's a gremlin he's a really
good-looking [ __ ] dude he's
significantly hotter than he's hot I
wouldn't say that I say like just
objectively speaking if he didn't dress
like a [ __ ] dweeb he would actually
look yeah he wasn't wearing you know I
think it's that gamer image that's put
upon him they look at this loser you
know face wise that pulls a [ __ ]
handsome as dude man I got your back bro
come on now why are we building is very
weird why are we building each other are
we doing a charity thing cuz I would
understand if it was like David so dubs
this woman
United mean then even be I'd be like -
what are you thinking bro know if people
finds out Nikki everyone would be like
this guy's the biggest [ __ ] idiot you
are that's what you again Wow and it's
not even a great picture that's not a
good picture you know yeah yeah yeah
she's all glammed up he doesn't have to
be I wish we could get see a video of
their personalities to judge he doesn't
have to be glad why his teeth are dude
yeah he does he works out a lot he go
but the he doesn't even have to have
glam photos well that
is from the video that I'm telling you
guys about like him explaining the real
reason so what do you think hey man I'm
gay for you all right there's no I get
it
you're definitely like a little HomeLife
David huh so nice is my coming-out video
okay we change the title of this video
was yes there was a reason it's taking
so long for him to propose it's a
domestic violence video
he's coming out because Mariel beats him
what are the popular titles for stuff
like this
I've been lying to you guys I have
something to tell you or something yeah
no it's always like god I haven't
proposed to my girlfriend yeah I likes
me some penis there you go penis you
couldn't say it without it sounded like
you're about to do chores that II just
want to feel the real reason I want to
tell you guys the real reason who's tell
I want to know so when they first
started dating because they've been
dating for three years when I first
started dating that he would post a lot
of videos with her a lot of vlogs and
all this stuff and then he kind of
mentioned to her like oh look check out
how much money I could be making on
YouTube and then once she realized that
he says that she started asking for her
cut of his earnings because because she
was in the videos cuz she's in the
videos and because she's also like
driving fans to his page because she'll
wear his shirts like on like when she's
doing the weather or whatever and so she
broke up a written law of couples so
then she said like you know what this
feels funny like morally weird to give
you money so how about anything you want
like I'll pay for it and I'll take care
of you and I'll support you and whatever
I'll pay all the bills because they live
together for some time and so like I
guess they were fine with that because
that worked out for some not even that
that you that's weird
it's like if you it's weird if you're if
you're in a committed relationship and
you think that you're gonna stay
together why is that an issue you just
help each other and help each other out
to help each other out
yeah unless you it's like a it's like
you know we work with our cup like our
significant others a lot but in in like
our specific situation there's an
agreement it's like you do this portion
of the work and and that's kind of like
boss employee relationship but then
there's all the extras that we don't
charge for it's like hey you're my vlog
now you owe me X dollar like that's like
yeah but maybe it's weird maybe he just
doesn't understand how hot she is
I'm trying to understand the breaking
point of this relationship where he was
just like you know what I don't want to
be with this girl anymore
he says that he wanted to buy her a car
he tells her like hey I want to buy you
a car because you know like you like to
go to the gym a lot and I don't want to
have to drive you every time you want to
go in the middle of the night and plus
like you deserve it you're such a great
girlfriend whatever he wanted to buy her
a car but then he says hey but I want to
film this like I want to make a video
about me buying you a car and she said
no so then that's when he was like cool
you know what like I need to make Jesus
he's saying that he has to balance his
livelihood with his relationship and
then if she oh she would also forbid him
from seeing certain friends and that she
was like rolling I hate that word that's
possessive yeah like really and the fact
that like you know she wanted she sucked
up fun out of there but we need to hear
who gives a [ __ ] you're her sight too
but all she said what she ended up
tweeting this thing of like Michelle and
Barack Obama and the thing said like
woman's true loyalty is tested when her
man has nothing and then a man's true
loyalty is tested when he has everything
that was like when she tweeted out
immediately after that but then all
these people responding to as she was
with him when he had nothing and he's
dumping her when he is oh he would
choose what they would he had nothing to
do all I see the point is here that a
lot of people are just calling her gold
digger and just giving she's a gold
digger and she's not a gold digger as
two people couldn't come to an agreement
because one person thinks like they
should get paid for making an appearance
and she does have value in the videos no
she's like driving fans to yeah but it's
just they didn't see eye to eye in that
like I kind of side more with the guy
because I wouldn't feel comfortable
unless we had the preset agreement yeah
the preset agreement I agree that it's
like hey you're gonna be in like 90
something percent of my videos I'm gonna
share my like channel revenue with you
like you know that pays fair but it's
like hey once in a while I'm gonna be
vlogging in the house and you're just
gonna be conveniently there and it's
that's that's a little different I don't
understand why it's so weird because I
always just feel like it's like hey
let's monetize this be tight and it's
like yeah be tight like well why is it
like it's like hey if I if I give you a
car and we thought wouldn't that be cool
and she's like no because she wants to
probably not feel like she's dependent
on someone yeah or appear like that to
the public
she's a product it's video yeah yeah
yeah because it blurs the line of you
know am I doing this for love and not
you know cuz I feel that way or is it
because I'm trying to take advantage of
like what a great guy I agree with that
it's you want to make a video showing
how good of a guy he was instead of just
like giving her a car cuz well I'll put
it like this you you you want to say
this kinda sounds insensitive like you
should have known what you got into you
you're dating a [ __ ] young as dweeby
youtuber yeah what else are they gonna
[ __ ] to you that's the only way they
make money like I'm not knocking on him
but that's their life you know that is
what you signed up for plus giving a
cars away as always does well on
youtubes but yeah it's like you can't
let go that opportunity every time I do
a car video those videos degree yeah I
have noticed and I don't know these
people's personal lives but I have
noticed because we have friends that
started with no subscribers right and
they're like nerdy dudes and then they
got big and they've never gotten girls
before and so even though they have a
hot girlfriend it doesn't matter they
haven't had this much attention coming
from girls before because they were
always nerdy and so then they get like a
big head and like kya kind of cocky
about it like oh like I could get any
girl I want I may be caught [ __ ] 15
or all the big punks yeah
happens every single time I wasn't gonna
go there but it happens every time
I [ __ ] love those guys man it's so
funny because like it's not the fact
that I I look down on the dude I looked
down on the [ __ ] girls you know it's
like that guy not reason with that age
no yeah it's like yo I'm trying to
convince you that this boy with perfect
smooth features who doesn't look like
he's ever [ __ ] a chick because he'll
never [ __ ] a chick like I'm trying to
convince you that you shouldn't
he appears alpha in her eyes yeah that's
the because their standards are low I
mean let's put it into perspective food
our standards in high school was garbage
cuz we never had cream of the crop [ __ ]
yeah so we don't know what what's a good
standard quality [ __ ] and I think that's
the same thing for like young people is
like I mean [ __ ] dude my my epitome and
my [ __ ] dream woman was a [ __ ]
girl on a lowrider magazine cover I
think it still is bro maybe
did she ever gotta try telling a
fifteen-year-old maybe try telling a
fifteen-year-old not to be into one
direction like five years ago good luck
bro good luck you're going down every
time
[Music]
[Music]